thanks for that testing for covid19
right now it's a major struggle but
there are some places in the valley many
places that are making sure covid tests
are available to you but some sites are
perhaps lesser known sally jeremiah live
near windmill and rainbow with more on
these lesser-known sites until now we're
going to let them know where they are
now sally
brian while the unlv location may have
been the most popular when it comes to
cobit 19 testing my photographer and i
went to several other locations across
the valley you might have not known
about
the demands have been very high
just a matter of just having them in
stock for a day we went out of stock
immediately william godoy is a pharmacy
tech at vesper specialty pharmacy
they've been working around the clock to
provide cova tests to those who need
them the first batch of tests that we
ordered
we immediately sold out
around two o'clock in the afternoon
yesterday and then we placed the order
for more take a look at this long line
of people wanting to get tested godoy
says they are also getting non-stop
calls carlos morales had a hard time
finding a test i went to walgreens and
cvs first to try to find one of those at
home covet tests and they were all sold
out i decided to go on the
southern nevada health district website
to find a testing center the health
district is working with partners to
evaluate current testing needs in our
community however appointments are
recommended as for morales he found a
test at umc quick care they took my name
down
they asked if i had an appointment i
guess you could make appointments but i
hadn't
and then they had me wait in the car
all said and done the whole process took
about two hours
out here live an update on that unlv
testing site it's moving to the parking
lot of sam boyd stadium the unlv
testing site will close down thursday
and reopen at sam boyd on sunday now
hours remain from 5 30 to 10 30 p.m for
now reporting live in the southwest part
of the valley sally jaramillo live local
now